bonsoir mona lors le président de la
république on le disait s'est exprimé à
20 heures qu'est ce qu'on doit retenir
ce soir de son intervention
alors il faudrait commencer déjà par
dire que c'est une prise de parole
symbolique au regard de la gravité des
événements le président de la république
a tout d'abord défini la stratégie
française dans ce cas aux afghans le
visage fermé le ton grave il a exprimé à
son extrême la préoccupation face à la
prise du pouvoir des talibans c'est un
tournant historique aux conséquences
majeures at il dit les donc après revenu
sur l'opération militaire qui est en
cours qui mobilise deux avions de
l'armée de l'air simplement pour aller
ressortissants français encore bloqués à
kaboul mais pas seulement il a exprimé
sa solidarité face aux afghans les
afghans qui ont travaillé aux côtés à
des français ne seront pas laissés pour
abandon je vous propose de l'écouter
l'urgence absolue est de mettre en
sécurité nos compatriotes qui doivent
tous quitté le pays ainsi que les
afghans qui ont travaillé pour la france
non ressortissants ont été programmés y
progressivement évacués en anticipation
ces dernières semaines nous sommes en
contact avec tous les français qui
veulent rejoindre le sol national qui se
trouve à l'aéroport militaire à
l'aéroport civil ou sur le site
historique de l'ambassade où la
situation demeure préoccupante
je veux ici remercier nos représentants
sur place nos diplomates policiers
militaires pour leur engagement et leur
courage
remercier aussi nos alliés américains
indispensable pour mener à bien ces
évacuations
la france est l'un des très rares pays à
avoir décidé de maintenir sur place
jusqu'au bout les moyens de protéger
ceux qui ont travaillé pour elle nous
avons aussi anticiper les opérations
d'évacuation dans les dernières semaines
tous les employés afghans des structures
françaises qui pouvait être menacés
ainsi que leurs familles ce qui
représente plus de 600 personnes ont
ainsi pu être accueillis et pris en
charge dans de bonnes conditions dans
notre pays
vous l'avez compris la situation est
très grave et elle est prise très au
sérieux à l'état menée en tout cas cette
situation à déstabiliser toute la région
la principale crainte du président états
de l'union européenne et bien elle
s'éclate ganis temps deviennent le foyer
du terrorisme écouter
notre action visera à continuer de
lutter activement contre le terrorisme
islamiste sous toutes ses formes des
groupes terroristes sont présents en
afghanistan et chercheront à tirer
profit de la déstabilisation le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies devra donc
apporter une réponse responsable et unis
j'ai échangé sur ce point avec le
premier ministre johnson et nous
prendrons des initiatives communes dans
les prochaines heures
le retour de la stabilité passera par
une telle action politique et
diplomatique au sein du conseil de
sécurité
l'afghanistan ne doit pas redevenir le
sanctuaire du terrorisme qu'il a été
c'est un enjeu pour la paix la stabilité
internationale contre un ennemi commun
le terrorisme et ceux qui le soutiennent
à cet égard nous feront également tout
pour que la russie les états unis et
l'europe puisque efficacement coopérer
car nos intérêts sont bien les mêmes
le chef de l'état à la répéter la france
sera un côté des afghans et des afghanes
mais il a été également très claire
cette crise elle va engendrer l des flux
migratoires et ce n'est pas à la france
d'en assumer seule les conséquences
merci beaucoup mona pour toutes ces
précisions mohamoud dès lors en direct
depuis l'elysée